bom dia é hoje eu queria contar três
talvez com vocês sobre mim e eu aprendi
sobre perseverança primeira história é
sobre como eu arrumei meu primeiro
emprego
me formei em 2009 uma faculdade pequena
em califórnia
me formei em relações internacionais e
como muitos novos
eu não sabia o que eu queria fazer na
vida é por muito tempo participei em
processos seletivos dos meus amigos
porque ele estava tinha tudo resolvido
na vida então eu entrei nos processos
com eles
me candidatei mas a estratégia não
estava funcionando bem dar um dia eu
tive a grande idéia de mudar tudo de
criar uma lista de empresas e marcas que
eu mais admirava do mundo incluem entrar
em contato com cada um de vocês com cada
um deles
eu fiz a lista só que só pensei em uma
marca e uma marca pouco conhecida
daí eu falei 'bom deve ser o único este
ano que está mirando um emprego nessa
empresa é essa empresa é tem um produto
que é molho de pimenta oriental chamadas
iraty é pouco conhecido no brasil se
você buscar fundo é na liberdade você
vai encontrar mas na época também não
estava bem conhecido esse produto
então falei bom é é um produto que me
apaixonei na faculdade eu achei sempre
uma garrafa só no refeitório chegava
cedo só para garantir que essa essa
garrafa estava na minha mesa e aos
poucos eu reparei que outros têm a mesma
idéia
então eu comecei a ter mais concorrência
e da eu sabia que eu tinha primeiro
sinal que esse produto tinha potencial e
aos poucos na minha vida eu vi que
apareceu mais lugar eu fui pro
restaurante apareceu lá fui para o
supermercado mais tradicional eu achei é
escondida ou a nos fundos também então é
eu falei bom como eu vou arrumar um
emprego na cidade
é eu decidi que eu vou primeiro
pesquisar no google pegar um e mail
mandar meu currículo
claramente eu sou o único que vai mandar
um e-mail do dia então eles vão me
responder
não me responderam daí eu falei beleza é
preciso ligar pra eles
eu vou ligar pra eles explicar a minha
paixão é de cinco minutos dossiê ou
porque quem não tem cinco minutos para
falar com o recém formado que quer falar
sobre sua paixão não rolou recepcionista
não me deixou é e então eu falei 'bom eu
vou escrever uma carta porque hoje em
dia quem escreve uma carta que escrevi
uma carta não responderam
eu até pensei 'bom eu preciso faça mais
conteúdo então eu decidi que eu vou
comprar o papel mais fino que tem na
loja é vou escrever mais uma carta mas
antes eu vou ler um livro sobre tabasco
é entender o que deu certo na história
deles e vou demonstrar a eles que não só
quer que eu vou mostrar que eu sei de
business de o que eles fizeram diferente
e eu mandei essa carta do japão e no
mesmo envelope estrangeiro quando eu
estava lá com minha família porque eu
falei quem não abre o envelope enviado
de fora com endereço de retorno em
japonês que eu achei que com essa
empresa talvez até que seria positivo
enquanto esperava isso é e eu tive uma
vida feliz e um desempregado que eu ia
pra academia eu sair com meus amigos e
um dia uma amiga me convidou para uma
festa
eu fui para essa festa com ela que foi
festa do irmão dela é que eu acho que
tinha uns 26 anos com os amigos deles e
foi uma festa pra para o feriado foi
muito grande a gente beber muito e todo
mundo ficou a noite lá e no próximo dia
eu me acordei pra voltar pra casa sem
muita expectativa e da lembra que um dos
indianos lá que estava jogando ping pong
comigo é ele pediu uma carona e filó é
preciso voltar posso ir contigo então
embora a gente pegou a estrada a gente
parou no restaurante é em um restaurante
para almoçar o que a gente pediu comida
e eu sabia que não fomente não teria
cidade mas eu pedi pra garção para
tentar se tens iratxe traz pra mim não
que a tudo bem então não deu certo não
tinha cidade é esse cara me olhou
estranho e falou cara eu amo sirota é eu
comecei a explicar para ele todas minhas
tentativas pra entrar em contato com ele
é com cidade não estava dando certo e
ele foi o primeiro cara que não me
achava louco ele até entrou viu o jogo
comigo ele fala cara você já pensou em
mandar 11 teles ó só pra colocar um pé
pra dentro de uma expressão em inglês é
de colocar onde foi treinador é então
que mais a gente pode fazer e ele
começou a empolgar muito com a idéia
depois bom no fim será que nunca me
respondeu nunca fui trabalhar lá mas eu
fui trabalhar com esse indiano é ele era
um empreendedor e eu virei o aprendiz
dele e acabou sendo a melhor experiência
profissional é em dois e meio anos muito
intensos
eu já me senti muito mais preparado para
ser um empreendedor e daí eu queria
compartilhar a primeira lição que
aprendi sobre perseverança que se é
perseverante não é nunca desistir
pelo contrário às vezes você precisa
desistir da sua estratégia mas é
perseverante e nunca desistir da sua
paixão seja consistente com o que você
acredita que as pessoas certas vão te
encontrar
a segunda história que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês é sobre a minha
decisão de mudar pra cá eu vim para o
brasil em 2012
não falava português não conhecer
ninguém aqui
e pra mim eu já tinha clareza que eu
precisava mudar pará
o novo negócio nova oportunidade mas eu
não sabia ainda então pela segunda vez
na minha vida eu não sabia por onde
começar
então comecei a contar para os meus
amigos que estava pensando em mudar para
o brasil que foi um grande erro porque
eles começaram a falar como foi a
decisão mais errada que foi suicídio
profissional ficaria com esse buraco no
meu currículo
ninguém vai querer me me contratar
depois era inexplicável senão parece
sério você vai descartar sua rede
profissional que coisa mais importante
seguindo o meu chefe é para ter uma
carreira muito boa então eles falaram
muito sobre o que eu deveria fazer com a
minha vida eu falei para os meus pais
que sempre me apoiaram também eu falei
que eu já pedi demissão então eu juntei
as duas comunicações né porque acho que
faz mais rápido pedi demissão eu estava
pensando em mudar para o brasil é ele
tinha dificuldade em esconder a
preocupação quando eu falei isso para
eles é bom deu tudo certo
eu acho que essa foto ajudar o meu pai
fica mais tranqüilo
na verdade isso foto foi tirada bem no
início é na santa catarina quando o meu
primeiro amigo brasileiro me convidou
para a despedida de solteiro dele com 17
homens para bate e volta para a
oktoberfest em blumenau
então eu acho que eu tô meu morto no dia
seguinte recuperando
é mas mudar pra cá foi a melhor decisão
na minha vida em formas muito
inesperadas
eu conheci lugares que não imaginava que
existia eu aprendi uma língua que eu
nunca imaginava que eu ia aprender e eu
cresci muito pessoalmente e
profissionalmente muito fora da minha
zona de conforto
todos os dias é especialmente o primeiro
ano mas eu decidi que foi o que eu
precisava e refletindo eu chego na minha
segunda lição
sobre a perseverança o quanto mais fora
da caixa você quer viver sua vida ou
mais que outros vão duvidar de você
não viva a vida dos outros
siga seu próprio instinto e eu tenho
certeza que vai dar certo mas é difícil
porque nesses momentos vulneráveis
você não sabe se vai dar certo se a
grande decisão por isso é uma grande
decisão mas tem que lembrar que ninguém
sabe também o que é a melhor decisão
então é muito melhor seguir confiar em
você do que outras pessoas que têm
outras personalidades e outros valores
inclusive pessoas que te amo você tem
que tomar muito cuidado com quem se está
escutando quando você toma grandes
decisões em 2013
eu abrir uma agência com o meu sócio que
também americano
eu falo agência porque teve essa cara
a única diferença entre minha agência na
época isso agência hoje é que eu falei
que eu tinha uma falava que eu tinha uma
agência é que começamos no nosso
apartamento com um cliente que foi a
fase mais dura da minha vida eu não
falava português que dificultava muito a
comunicação é recrutar talentos também
foi um desafio aparentemente dois
gringos com um vocabulário de um criança
de cinco anos
com essas condições com uma proposta que
a gente jura que vamos pagar em dinheiro
no final do mês seu salário não inspira
muita confiança mas a gente foi
crescendo dia a dia a gente foi
melhorando ea gente se esforçou muito
nessa época é trabalhando até de
madrugada para recompensar por falta de
talento nossa equipe ea gente foi
crescendo e um dia o zelador falar olha
eu percebi isso estão operando um
negócio num prédio residencial
é vocês têm até o final do mês de
arrumar um novo escritório
você vai precisar arrumar um novo
apartamento também então ficou claro eu
acho que somente na época eu não entendi
por que ele estava falando então acho
que demorou mas finalmente sacamos é o
que a gente fez a gente disse dilma bom
precisamos de um escritório ainda não
temos o nosso cnpj então nenhum corretor
nossa ajudaria é nossa ajudava
então a gente fala beleza vamos bater
porta a porta em todos os prédios
comerciais num raio de 1 quilômetro
dessa área e vamos encontrar um néon
alguém que tem uma sala comercial e
ofereceu pagar em dinheiro que foi a
única opção
e a gente foi dividindo essa tarefa eu
fui um dia daí meu sócio foi outro dia a
gente acompanhou e por milagre a gente
encontrou um pequeno prédio é perto de
casa até que tinha um senhor que tinha
uma sala comercial de 30 metros
quadrados e ele aceitou dinheiro é três
meses de aluguel em depósito
a gente foi correndo pra caixa
eletrônica por cinco dias seguidos para
pegar o máximo da nossa conta pessoal
para sacar o dinheiro suficiente para
pagar ele
pagamos ele e nosso escritório bom não
ficam tão mais bonito é é um dos poucos
fotos que eu tenho na época é e mas a
gente tinha condições mínimas
a gente aprendeu muito no dia-a-dia
cometendo muitos erros
quase tudo a gente fez foi errado mas
por outro lado a gente sempre foi
honesta com a equipe tentando a
compartilhar o que a gente fez errado o
que não deu certo ea gente sempre busca
ser um pouco melhor e aos poucos a gente
cresceu
é isso foi a expansão do mesmo
escritório e aos poucos também a gente
encontrou bons talentos que não jogaram
o livro pela capa
então eles começaram a acreditar
e a gente foi crescendo crescendo e
finalmente é esse sala era uma sala de
30 metros quadrados cada vez que a gente
achou que a gente ia precisar mudar
abriu mais uma pequena sala do lado
então a gente acabou dominando
esse prédio é antigo mas chegou uma hora
que a gente não cabia mais
e a gente foi para um novo escritório
a gente foi para o novo escritório todo
mundo ajudou com a mudança porque não
tinha os recursos ainda então todo mundo
pegou uma parte gente se encontrou no
sábado a gente fez o a mudança para o
novo escritório e apesar apesar da crise
a gente foi crescendo
a gente chegou em 100 funcionários
depois chegamos em 200 funcionários e o
que eu aprendi pela experiência que
foram só três e meia curtos anos de
começar do nada sem investimento o que
eu aprendi na verdade eu ainda estou
aprendendo é que sucessos imediatos são
construídos lentamente tijolo por tijolo
e o melhor segredo que eu possa
compartilhar com vocês é focar no
dia-a-dia focar em ser um pouco melhor
do que ontem e a soma de tudo isso que
vai fazer a diferença
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]